hi guys Lucy here with an emotional
choice heavy GS news update for you
Walking Dead and Game of Thrones
developer telltale games are finally
opening up about their mysterious new IP
in an interview with games industry
international Telltale's given brunner
said i'll say we've spent a lot of time
experimenting over the last decade which
how powerful a storytelling tool
Interactive can be and when we thought
about building something from the ground
up that gave us absolutely everything we
could dream off as storytelling tools
the right kind of story the right kind
of setting the right kind of people
involved everything bruna went on to say
that tell tales new IP which represents
the first franchise the studio has ever
created is the perfect thing for the
company he said it kind of rose
organically and doing your first
original IP is a pretty big deal for any
company so it's something we're pouring
a lot of love into it's probably the
most ambitious thing the company has
ever done but we feel like we're ready
for it we're very excited to talk about
it but we can't say much more right now
but it is the perfect thing for us
curiouser and curiouser while we're not
sure what we'll tackle next apparently
telltale has been flooded with exciting
requests although he didn't name any
outright we used to spend a lot of time
knocking on people's doors trying to
explain to them what we meant by
playable story and seeing if we could be
able to apply our trade in their world
now we've got things that I just can't
believe that people are coming to us
either with properties they want us to
work on or creative to come and want to
work with us we definitely have people
coming to us from all angles and people
that are frankly just knocking our socks
off with how impressive they are and
they appreciate what we're doing and
want to work with us he added we're
constantly honored and amazed which
franchise would you like to see telltale
take on next let us know in the comment
section below for all the latest make
sure you stay tuned to gamespot com
you